y reforzar los controles de las
exportaciones de vacunas esta es la
estrategia de bruselas para asegurar a
los veintisiete- un mejor acceso al
preciado suero contra el coronavirus
concretamente el laboratorio sueco
británico astrazéneca no podrá exportar
sus dosis producidas en la unión europea
hasta que haya compensado el retraso en
la entrega en el continente una decisión
aprobada por varios jefes de estado
incluido el presidente francés el sutil
límite mismo de apoyo los mecanismos de
control de las exportaciones
establecidos por la comisión europea
apoyo que hay que bloquear todas las
exportaciones que se hagan mientras los
laboratorios no respeten sus compromisos
con los europeos
este bloqueo se dirige en particular a
reino unido señalado de haber recibido
21 millones de dosis producidas en la
unión europea sin cumplir con sus
contratos de entrega con el bloque en
total- astrazéneca sólo ha suministrado
30 millones de dosis al bloque europeo
en lugar de las 120 millones prometidas
esto es inaceptable para la presidenta
de la comisión europea obedeció loc
y nombró en total el número de personas
totalmente vacunadas en europa es de 18
2 millones así que el 4,1 por ciento de
la población ya ha recibido las dos
inyecciones pero por supuesto sabemos
que podríamos haber sido mucho más
rápidos si todas las empresas
farmacéuticas hubieran cumplido sus
contratos contracts se está llevando a
cabo conversaciones entre los 27 y reino
unido- para llegar a un acuerdo sobre el
suministro de vacunas el objetivo de la
unión para final de verano es
convertirse en el mayor productor de
vacunas del mundo e inmunizar al 70% de
su población adulta